you
[Music]
nobody doesn't love your world and let
me back up when we think of places you
might find life we typically think of
the Goldilocks zone around the star
where water would be liquid in its
natural state and if you get a little
too close to the star heat would
evaporate the water and you don't have
it anywhere it's gone too far away would
freeze and neither of those states of
h2o are useful to life as we know it we
need liquid water so you can establish
this Green Zone this habitable zone this
Goldilocks zone where if you find a
planet orbiting their pay it's a good
chance it could have liquid water let's
look there first for life as we know it
now it turns out that this source of
heat of course is traceable to the Sun
and if you go farther out everything
would or should be frozen all other
things being equal
but Europa a moon of Jupiter sitting
well outside of the Goldilocks zone is
kept warm not from energy sources
traceable to the Sun but from what we
call the tidal forces of Jupiter itself
so Jupiter and surrounding moons are
actually pumping energy into Europa and
how does it do that as you rope it
orbits Jupiter its shape changes it's
not fundamentally different from tides
rising and falling on earth the shape of
the water system of the earth is
responding to tidal forces of the moon
and when you do that to a solid object
the solid object is is stressing and
because of this a consequence of this is
that you're pumping energy into the
object it is no different from when you
say anyone who's familiar with racquet
sports endure racquet sports you could
be a racquetball or squash you say let's
warm up the ball before we start playing
you want to hit it around a few times
you are literally warming up the ball
it's not just simply let's get loose if
how you are distorting it every time you
smack it and then the resilience of the
ball pops it back into shape and every
time you do that every smack you're
pumping energy into the ball it's not
fundamentally different from what's
going on in orbit around Jupiter so you
have this frozen world Europa completely
frozen on its surface but you look at
you look at the surface and they're
cracks in the ice
they're ridges in the ice where there's
a crack and it shifted and then refroze
so this Ridge has a discontinuity in the
crack and it continues in another place
so what this tells you is that Europa
cannot be completely frozen because if
it were nothing would be moving you look
at the surface of Europa the frozen
surface they're like ice chunks that are
like shifted and refrozen and shift it
again it looks just like if you fly over
than the the Arctic Ocean fly over the
Arctic Ocean in the winter these are ice
sheets that are breaking and refreezing
all the time it's the same signature as
that so all of us are convinced that
beneath this icy surface is an ocean of
liquid water and there's no reason to
think it wouldn't have been liquid for
billions of years on earth where we find
liquid water we find life wherever we
find liquid water we find life even
places like the Dead Sea why did anybody
call it a dead sea because the
microscope hadn't yet been invented and
sure of them maybe there's no
macroscopic vertebrate fishes but
microbes have no problems thriving and
practically any condition under which
you would find liquid water so what this
means not only do we have a source of
heat outside of the gold
zone we have conditions under which life
could be thriving and knowing that this
is possible has completely broadened the
net that we are casting in search for
life in the universe no longer is it to
limit let's find a 72 degree a tidal
pond and sea life forming there no life
is pretty Hardy and if it takes liquid
water weak that may be the other place
in the solar system that is teeming with
some form or another of life so yeah we
all want to go to Europa period we got
to go ice fishing though because you got
to cut a hole or melt a hole you got to
get there somehow because this sheet of
ice by some estimates or several
kilometers thick and so it'll take some
effort to get through that which we
haven't really fully figured out yet but
it's an engineering problem not a
science problem so the clever engineers
should be able to figure that one out
and by the way Europe is not the only
one of these moons in the outer solar
system that kept warm by these sort of
tidal stress forces there are other
moons that feel the same influx of
energy so for example IO that's the
innermost moon of Jupiter that suffers
from this phenomenon even more and that
moon is so hot there are volcanoes
erupting from within there it is it is
rendered molten whatever solid parts of
that moon there are and so in fact the
most volcanically active place in the
solar system is IO one of the moons of
Jupiter and we don't know how to sustain
life under temperatures that hot so but
it's a reminder that if you're looking
for sources of energy we no longer need
to be anchored to a host star in our
search for life in the universe
[Music]